hello and welcome to the cheeky science
show where in this video we're going to
talk about alpha-ketoglutarate
and a recent paper that came out in
nature communications
that has shown that supplementation of
alpha-ketoglutarate
increases bone mass of aged mice and can
protect
bone loss in adult mice and they also
show that treatment with
alpha-ketoglutarate ameliorates the
age-related phenotypes of
bone-derived stem cells and this seems
to be occurring at the epigenetic level
so there's a lot of concepts to get
through in this video so to break it
down i'll begin by giving an overview to
alpha-ketoglutarates which i'll refer to
as akg from now on as it's much easier
for me to say
then we'll look at the results of this
publication and analyze what they found
out in this paper and then we'll compare
this and have a look at
and how this recent news correlates to
what's already known about
supplementation with akg
and then we'll bring all of this
information together to kind of get an
understanding of what we know so far
about akg and then lastly
excitingly i will be doing my first ever
giveaway which will be a free bottle
of a supplement which i'll disclose at
the end of this video
and this is partly to say thank you for
all of your support and
contributions to the channel so far in
terms of commenting liking whatever
i really do appreciate it and also to
announce some support that i'm getting
from donotage.org
but as i said i'll talk about that at
the end of the video so firstly then
what is alpha-ketoglutarate or akg
well you're currently looking at it and
it's a metabolite found within all of
our cells
and it plays a really important role in
metabolism
as it is a key component of the krebs
cycle
the krebs cycle results in the
production of reduced form of nad plus
nadh and then this is used by the
mitochondria to generate
atp which is the energy source of a cell
so akg is really important for cells
however multiple studies have shown that
the levels of akg
decline with age almost akg declines of
age
the incidence of osteoporosis increases
with age
and osteoporosis is the most prevalent
metabolic bone disease
that results in weaker bones and an
increased fracture risk
and it's characterized by reduced bone
mass and changes in the bone micro
architecture
now akg and osteoporosis are both topics
i recently spoke about
in separate videos and so i was really
interested when this recent study came
out just the other week
alpha-ketoglutarate ameliorates
age-related osteoporosis
via regulating histone methylations now
that's a bit of a mouthful
so let's break it down firstly why did
the researchers decide to bring these
two different topics together
well it is known that one of the causes
of age-related
osteoporosis is due to the dysfunction
of
bone marrow mesenchymal stem cells and
these mesenchymal stem cells can
generate
several different types of cells
including cells found in cartilage bone
and fat
however one of the hallmarks of aging
are exhaustion of these stem cells
meaning that they can no longer divide
and effectively produce these different
cell types
and so this is where akg comes in
because akg has been shown to extend the
lifespan of worms and more recently
mice and they've also been shown to
maintain the pluripotency of embryonic
stem cells
and even moreover administration of akg
can promote bone development in growing
rats and lambs
and so the oldest thought would be
interesting to see how akg
could influence age-related osteoporosis
so first up the authors looked at aged
mice
and found that as previously reported
the levels of akg decline with age
and these levels were rescued when the
aged mice were supplemented with akg
and this rescue appears to be dose
dependent whereby the more akg given to
the mice
the greater the recovery of the akg
levels
and this recovery of akg levels was
shown to correlate
in the aged mice with an increase in the
vertebral bone volume
as you can see here it is worth noticing
though that
whilst the akg levels match that of the
young mice when the old mice were
supplemented with akg
the recovery isn't quite as significant
when you look at the bone volume
however bone volume changes are likely
to be a lot slower and longer
than just changes in akg levels however
interestingly
they also isolated some of these
bone-derived mesenchymal stem cells from
aged female mice
that were treated with akg at 0.75
for one month and they cultured these
cells and what they could see was that
the osteogenic potential of these cells
were much greater than
control mice that weren't given akg for
example this is reflected
in the increased expression of
osteogenic related genes
so what this effectively means is that
these stem cells seem
like they have a greater potential to
produce more bone cells
now whilst age-associated osteoporosis
occurs in both males and females
a primary cause of osteoporosis is
post-menopausal estrogen deficiency
and this is partly reflected in their
female mice that they were looking at
whereby you can see a rapid decline in
the trabecular bone mass
shortly after the female mice reached
sexual maturity
and this was a 77.5 reduction in the
bone volume
from 2 months old to 6 months old
however supplementation of 0.25
akg in the drinking water of the female
mice
actually attenuated the bone loss as you
can see here
the next thing they did in this study
was look at whether or not akg
could help accelerate bone defect
healing
and they did this by looking at aged
rats and so the reason behind this
is because the healing of bone defects
is postponed along with aging
and so in the setup they treated the
rats for two weeks with akg or they just
had control rats without
and then they performed the surgery
whereby they
induced damage in the femur bone of the
rats
and then two weeks afterwards they then
collected the samples to see
how the healing had been affected and
what you can see
here is that the rats treated with akg
had a much faster recovery and bone
volume
so as a quick recap so far we've seen
that akg attenuates age-related bone
loss
and also that akg accelerates bone
defects healing of aged rodents
now the part of the study that i liked
mainly because i'm biased due to my
interest in cellular senescence
was when they looked at how akg could
influence the hallmarks of aged
mesenchymal stem cells
and so one of these hallmarks is
cellulosin essence and there are many
ways in which a cell can become
senescent
which is when a cell stops dividing and
secretes a variety of different
factors including inflammatory markers
but one way cells can become senescent
is by replicate of senescence
so the authors isolated again these bone
marrow mesenchymal stem cells
from 18 month old mice and then treated
these cells
with 2 millimolar akg and the treated
cells
not only exhibited a longer lifespan
compared to the control cells
but they also had a reduction of many
senescence markers including p16 p21
p53 my favorite protein and interleukin
6. and what was also striking
is that the cells treated with akg also
had
extremely low levels of the
phosphorylated form of gamma h2ax
which is the marker of dna damage and so
this is really
interesting however so far hasn't really
given us any insight into how
akg might be performing these effects so
to look into this they continued to work
with these
isolated mesenchymal stem cells and what
they
noticed was that akg supplementation
significantly reduced the levels of two
epigenetic marks
h3k9 trimethylation and h3k27
trimethylation
so these two methylation marks are
referred to as epigenetic marks
as they are found on top of the dna
sequence
and so dna is compacted within the
nucleus of our cells
by being wrapped around these histone
proteins and these two marks when
they're present on histone proteins
are commonly associated with
heterochromatin which
are densely packed regions of chromatin
and now having gone into this i feel
like this probably does deserve a video
of its own
so maybe we'll see a video on that
sometime soon but effectively
increases in these methylation marks has
also been associated with aging
and so seeing a reduction in those
levels by
akg is somewhat promising especially
with the h3k9 train methylation mark
i think it's very clear and so changes
in these methylation marks have been
associated with changes in gene
expression
which might be contributing to these akg
influences we've seen
on bone mass and in the reduced
senescence phenotype
and the authors subsequently support the
importance of these methylation
marks by inhibiting a d-methylase that
would usually remove the
methylation marks and by inhibiting this
d-methylase
they reduced the benefit of the akg
treatment
so the authors concluded that their
findings support that the effects of akg
on the mesenchymal stem cells in terms
of aging
relies at least partially on the
regulation of histone
modifications so how does this fit in
with previous work done
on akg well firstly the senescence work
reminded me of the cell metabolism paper
that i commented on
a couple of months ago now whereby they
sort of reduction in the inflammatory
markers in mice supplemented with akg
and so obviously both these studies have
used rodent models to try and understand
what akg is doing
and so this just makes me more curious
to eventually hopefully see
some human data with regards to akg
and as i mentioned in my last video in
akg the company behind that
publication are currently enrolling
participants for a larger randomized
double-blind
placebo-controlled clinical trial so
that would be interesting to see
however there is a better data regarding
akg in humans
for example this very short publication
showed that akg inhibited osteoporosis
development
in post-menopausal women and so this
directly goes in line with what we're
seeing
in these mice models in this paper and
this paper also reinforces the
importance of
epigenetics and the role that akg can
play in this for example it's also known
that
akg plays a role in dna demethylation by
acting as a cofactor for tet enzymes
that remove these methylation marks and
the other thing worth mentioning
is the publication that i mentioned
previously about how warmth seems to be
preventing bone loss
and the mechanism that underpins that
seems to be by an
increase in the level of spermatine and
so it raises the question of whether or
not
akg and berbazine could be used in
combination to have an enhanced effect
on ameliorating bone loss and so i think
that would be very interesting to
for a study to be done to examine that
but all in all this study reinforces the
potential therapeutic use of akg
and age-related osteoporosis and so
lastly as promised
in this video i will be doing a free
giveaway partly to say thank you for
your continued support on this channel i
really do appreciate it
and also to announce some support i'm
now going to be receiving from
donotage.org
who are dedicated to extending healthy
lifespan for as many people as possible
they also have a range of supplements on
cell and if you use the code
cheeky you will get 10 discount off your
order
and so now for the giveaway if you
comment below with some thoughts
opinions or some questions about the
research i've just talked about
you will be entered into this free
giveaway of 60 capsules of pure anime
from do not
age delivery will be free regardless of
where you live
and entries will close 48 hours of this
video publishing
and as a disclaimer i'm not a medical
doctor please check with your doctor
before you take any supplements and do
your own research about it
so good luck and i hope you've learned
something in this video and
as always thanks for listening